you know there's a lot that we can say  is of risk pertaining to democracy how  both sides are at each other's and we  have a terribly split uh world uh at the  same time I think that to watch the  democratic system work where everybody's  obeying the rules is just the most  wonderful thing because it's all  transparent with all different points of  view being able to come out and  transparently you get to decide on who  runs uh the government and how they  operate together and then these people  that are the chosen Representatives as  far flung as they are as different as  they are have to get together in a room  and make decisions in a way that uh is  best for uh the populations that they  represent so it's a beautiful and  miraculous thing to watch when it works  well of course we have major risks about  how it's work working well but I love  savoring this at this moment